dans la polémique autour de la première
ministre voici la dernière photo de
femme qui s'embrassent et qui couvrent
leur poitrine avec un écriteau finlande
d'abord publiées sur les réseaux sociaux
puis par les médias du pays elle a été
prise dans la résidence de sanaa marine
la chef du gouvernement qui a dû
s'excuser avant-hier expliquant que le
cliché et est inapproprié le lendemain
lors de cet événement organisé par son
parti elle se défend à nouveau au bord
des larmes
il nous fait perdre pied malaise et oui
le malaise
je suis mme et moi aussi j'ai parfois
envie de joie de lumière et d'amusement
au milieu de ces nuages sombres et cela
implique toutes sortes de photos et de
vidéos que je ne voudrais pas voir que
je sais que vous ne voudriez pouvoir et
pourtant on nous les montre à tous c'est
privé c'est la joie et c'est la vie
43% des français déclarent être
optimiste et déterminé ses 17% de plus
que l'an dernier deux explications à
cela la crise du coc vide semble
s'éloigner et le chômage préoccupations
principales des français depuis
cinquante ans est en baisse autre
enseignement 66% des français se disent
satisfaits de leur niveau de vie actuel
je serai pas pêcheur on ne pourrait pas
s'offrir 30 euros logé à midi et c'est
ça le bonheur c'est de pouvoir manger le
poisson qu'on l'a choisi il vient de
sortir de l'ornement les pauvres mais
que sur les régions
faut manger des choses saines et ça
c'est les scandinaves qui l'ont compris
regard des compagnies chinoises vont un
burger vegan saveurs viande humaine et
là ma question c'est qui a goûté guise
de valider la recette est de confirmer
la ressemblance je ne sais pas force est
de constater
que tout ne va pas bien dans le meilleur
des mondes le
nautile et hilary euros intègre aussi un
tir à 10 euros un tir outils et tyrannie
d'un euro une routine ray
quel boys band interprète la chanson
quand je rêve de toi en 1997 c'est
l'année de ma naissance ça ne veut rien
dire mozart est mort je le connais
c'est vrai l'habitacle est vache j'ai 20
ans et toi t'as quel âge
moi j'ai 29 ans et plus
le truc c'est que tu vois ils ont même
un parcours d'influenceurs
aujourd'hui ils ont une émission télé
qui fonctionne bien alors le
l'orientation c'est quoi ce serait plus
d'avoir et on en parle avec lens et ce à
la question un visa d'artistes autour de
leurs créneaux mais là il leur faut des
contrats avec des boîtes américaines
investisseurs parce qu'on lui a proposé
de monter une affaire soir au stade on
sait là on a besoin de ton aide à
44,3 milliards d'euros c'est le montant
des dividendes versés aux actionnaires
par les grandes entreprises françaises
au deuxième trimestre un chiffre en
forte hausse de 32 7% parmi les
entreprises qui ont le plus augmenté
leurs dividendes figurent bnp paribas
sanofi l'assureur axa et le géant du
luxe lvmh
des chiffres qui s'expliquent par la
reprise économique après la crise du coc
vide nous explique en deux mots la
différence un visa d'artistes réalité et
c'est pas évident
d / sipa est reconnue quoi si les deux
messieurs
francis est vrai où les chanter ici on
ne peut pas oublier non mais c'est un
influenceur c'est pas un métier
arsenault des stores z je pourrais vous
parler comme ça au revoir pipi
ou
pour yahoo ou diarrhées ou des diarrhées
ou lien au lit
[Musique]
mais je n'ai jamais vu ça
personne des cheveux qui poussent sur
les bras comme sur la tête
[Rires]
je raconte aux autres que j'ai vu des
poils comme ça sur les bras d'un homme
personne ne me croira c'est incroyable
non je peux vraiment pas leur raconter
ça une rencontre que cette femme en
paddle n'est pas près d'oublier
cette baleine de plusieurs dizaines de
tonnes semble s'être fait une nouvelle
amie
lors de sa migration large de la
patagonie le mammifère marin a pris une
pause de quelques minutes pour jouer
autour de la planche
c'est presque un numéro de danse
aquatique que lui a offert le cétacé
[Musique]